right jimmy garoppolo in the news as he
continues to be on the 49ers roster 25
million dollar
total compensation package for 2021 greg
bedard recently suggested this news came
to us by way of our friends and
colleagues at nbc sports bay area that
plan a
for the new england patriots at
quarterback is to find a way to get
jimmy garoppolo and frankly chris i
think they can get him
simply by sitting
and waiting you're not going to trade
for a 25 million dollar compensation
package same as tom brady you're not
going to trade for that nobody's going
to pay him that this year so you sit and
you wait for jimmy garoppolo to get cut
and you know what if there's a way to
let don yee
agent for garoppolo and brady know that
there's a landing spot in new england
if he does get cut then that emboldens
ye and garoppolo to say we're not taking
a pay cut if you want us to take a pay
cut you're just going to have to cut me
so there's a path it's not all that
complicated does it make sense though
for the patriots to roll out the red
carpet for the guy they traded to san
francisco four years ago well i i want
to say this right i mean yes that makes
sense
i don't doubt that that new england
wants jimmy garoppolo i think you're
crazy though in thinking that they're
just going to give cut jimmy garoppolo
they're not going to just cut him well
they got to have somebody else a
quarterback who would they have right
that's what i'm saying if they wait they
wait wait wait for your guy kyle
shanahan to get sam darnold or someone
else that they regard as an upgrade and
then that's when they cut jimmy
garoppolo
teddy bridgewater they're making calls
about teddy bridgewater reportedly i
guess the bar apparently is low
respect like we talked about yes i mean
that that one was the one that shocked
me certainly and if i was jimmy g that'd
be the one that i'd be like pissed at
like we talked about last week a little
bit the 49ers like they got three
options to me this can go three ways
right and because i think we're gonna
talk about jimmy g in new england we
gotta talk about what the hell the 49ers
are gonna do
right to have a quarterback right to
give him to to new england and make that
happen chris sims coming out of
retirement well three years younger than
tom brady yep and a lot worse so that
nobody's gonna want me um but the 49ers
i mean of course they could keep jimmy g
and then just find a backup for
insurance they could go that route i i
don't think that's dead yet i wouldn't
would you pay him 25 million i i
wouldn't love that but i i think with
that contract right now this day and age
for a guy that
you know wins football games i don't
think it's crazy i could swallow that
he wins he wins when he plays i know i
get that i understand that but i think
the concert 22 wins chris 22 wins 23
games missed
i i i i got you all all the way the but
so if they keep them okay i don't know
maybe they can squeeze them or do
something like that if they want but
either way they need the backup if they
do keep them they need somebody viable
no more like uh you know johnny we don't
know your name and you're not that good
so you lose games for the 49ers you got
to get somebody else like credible
behind them so there's that option then
there is the
um
they can do the draft you know they're
sitting there at number 12. i don't know
i don't that's going to be risky that's
going to be no man's land i don't know
if you'll get any of the top three guys
there so you'd probably have to maybe
trade up and do that i don't think
that's going to happen i don't know i
don't look at that the 49ers are kind of
in like win now right now this second
mode do they really want to bring the
rookie in and do that i know shanahan's
a mastermind and all that and he could
probably still win a lot of football
games that way but there's going to be
you know some bumps in the road and all
that and then the last thing is what i'm
thinking is going to happen
that the jets are looking at zach wilson
and michael lafleur's going wait my
brother matt leflore's in green bay and
he's got aaron rodgers and wait the guy
that might be here at number two and i
expect to be a number two he plays just
like aaron rodgers and oh yeah i'm gonna
run the same offense my brother runs up
in green bay so i would think that that
would leave sam darnold on the table and
in my heart of hearts or of anything i i
could see that happening that now
darnold just like we saw with the lions
rams inside deal coaches and people that
move from one organization the other
that that conversation happens and he
goes there and now
new england and the 49ers also have
history together shanahan and belichick
we know there's a respect thing there i
mean there's been it's been widely
documented so i think when you connect
the dots right there you just go it's
almost like too obvious
not to think it's gonna happen honestly
right well and you could see
garoppolo agreeing to a restructured
contract as part of a trade would send
him
back to new england and uh if he's going
to take a haircut at least he controls
his destination he goes to where he and
he doesn't go through the indignity of
being cut i think there's value in that
from the standpoint for jimmy garoppolo
but yeah look i hey i
we suggested this as it related to brad
holmes brad holmes the lions gm now
coming from the rams where he was the
director of college scouting certain
amount of gratitude for being put in the
position to get that job so
you you provide the the out
for the rams for jared goff and you know
jared goff you like jared goff they want
to move on from jared goff so you take
jared goff and give them matthew
stafford and he also pick up a couple of
first-round picks in the third round
it's not like the lions get gave away
stafford yeah but having that
relationship and having that that level
of i wouldn't be where i am right now if
it wasn't for you there's that that
sense of loyalty and gratitude that can
maybe grease the skids for getting a
darnold to san francisco deal done right
then allowing for
for the the 49ers to show their
gratitude to the jets by helping solve
the patriots
quarterback and sending garoppolo back
to new england well the other thing too
would like the cut situation too that
just comes to my mind here and where i
don't think you know
there is
you got new england of course who has
history with jimmy g we know that then
there's houston down there and depending
on what happens at sean watson listen
they're running the new england system
there they've kept the same staff or the
same guys you know on that offensive
side of the ball
so they're and nick casario of course
was in new england as well so i would
think they're a team that if they do
trade out desean watson maybe they're
another team that gets involved and goes
hey can we get a three-way
three-way trade here could we figure
this out so that's where i don't
envision a jimmy garoppolo cut
if it's played right they should be able
to trade him and at least get something
even when we know it's inevitable that
yeah they've they've moved on or they're
making a move for sam darnold or
whatever the case may be
yeah i i
i agree with everything you're saying
and it just feels like something that
that quite possibly
will happen could happen maybe they hold
on to garoppolo until after they
draft someone if that's what they decide
to do because if you know if you've
traded garoppolo
to new england
then you've told the world you're
looking at the first round for a
quarterback i'm i'm thinking back to
that where they sit at number 12 and
they're trying to trade up you know all
the stuff
there's you're right there's different
ways they can approach this and uh
it all comes down to what number one
kyle shanahan thinks of the incoming
rookies number two what he thinks to the
other available options number three
what he truly thinks of jimmy garoppolo
not the stuff that he says publicly but
the stuff that he believes in his heart
of hearts that same heart that caused
him to turn jimmy garoppolo into bob
greasy from the first drive of the third
quarter of the win over the vikings in
the 2019 playoffs through the end of the
nfc championship game where it was i'm
not giving you the keys to the car
we're gonna run the ball run the ball
run the ball run the ball run the ball
now at some point between then and the
super bowl they trusted jimmy garoppolo
again but that's the question do they
trust him to run the offense do they
trust him to stay healthy do they trust
him to pay him 25 million dollars yeah
for this year i think that you can't
answer all three of those questions yes
no
you're right you can't well then and
that is the reason we're talking about
this right now because when you can't
answer all those three yes
that's when you're not sure and you do
look for an upgrade and of course the
biggest one is like you've talked about
just the availability that's scary in
itself that is i mean that's scary to
coaches i i've been in you know teams
locker rooms and things like that i mean
coaches are talking about that you know
in closed door enclosed rooms you know
about the quarterback can he stay
healthy can we depend on them all of
those type of things so it's a real
issue there's no doubt about it we'll
see where it goes i mean that's going to
be another one that's going to be
interesting and that's where we need a
few of these dominoes to fall to figure
out who the hell is where this year
playing quarterback with russell wilson
deshaun watson and all of this stuff
yeah for all the expected movement of
the quarterback carousel this year there
still hasn't been much
but but
we're nine days away from the start of
the new league year and that's when all
sorts of crazy things will happen and
that's when we'll start to get some
clarity because teams that are looking
to address their quarterback needs
aren't going to sit around and wait and
wait and wait is desean watson going to
be traded is russell wilson going to be
traded is this guy going to be available
they're going to go find their guy and
go forward with their plan for 2021
otherwise they end up
with
a c level or d level quarterback for
2021 and that's the kind of thing that
can get guys fired
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports